will our country be governed by the
people for will it be governed by the
corrupt political flash the political
and media elite have no idea what it's
like to be living in a paycheck paycheck
to paycheck basis there's a please Adam
digit answer present the factories and
the field ever since I child how can you
have the people who are working like you
know sewers and dumpster man who like
make this community like run and they're
all minimum wage and stuff and I mean
they do just as much work as a
congressman think it's unfair because
they're the ones who decide what their
salary is I wish I could choke sig-
salary then be awesome they're all
enriching each other and passing our
heart tax money
stem cells still eats a complete Lisa
right
those politicians that are up at the
White House they should have the same
health care insurance that we do and
they get free health care everything
other people don't if they have to you
live the way we do with paid phone
health insurance their thing they might
think they're really
I mean seriously drain the swamp sums it
up